so
today i'm going to show you how to clean
dirty airpods from start to finish
we offer all kind of phone repairs we
specialize
in iphone repairs mainly whatever is
portable and smart we can repair it
so when people bring in their earpods
the main problem they have is
low volume either on boat or just on one
side of the airport
usually they come like in the condition
that customers are
going to throw them away and they just
come to me as a last resort so i'm going
to show you three different pairs of
earpods in three different conditions
this pair of airpods of course they are
not cleaned uh
of course the main main brown thing is
is the earwax and
it's a piece of bacon or sausage or
carrot
nobody nobody really knows but uh i just
uh
pour a drop of pure alcohol and uh
leave them for a couple of seconds just
to soak in and
and use toothpick to to kind of release
the
the whatever is in there probably airbox
or something like that
i softened that with this short brush i
just trimmed them down to make them
harder
then i should just use vacuum cleaner to
suck everything out
[Music]
and then then repeat repeat repeat the
same process again and again
until it's uh until it's clean really
there's
two sets of mesh on in every airport
there's the one the steel one that you
see in front and there is one a little
bit smaller pitch one
behind it so you can see the second
clean clean second mesh behind it in in
those few open holes
the actual meshes is pretty clean most
of the holes are still open and
so this pair actually looks very bad but
it's still
quite loud and then usable
yeah this look at the wars these
airports they were still working you can
see
you can see some open holes there so the
the sound was still coming through it
was super super quiet
but it was still coming through that one
open
open hole in that mesh it's it makes a
difference really
it looks like they were lying around for
for a good while somewhere you know in
the corner because
uh like looks like a mold or something
like that
it's yeah they they were not the
cleanest ones that's for sure
i can see it seeing some better days you
can see the actual plastic it was
probably
chewed with by you know a small dog or
cat or
something like that you know because the
plastic itself like
that you never or maybe or maybe it was
showed by the owner
themselves you know like
visually the the left left one might
look much worse than the right one and
it's just a matter of
how many how many those holes in the net
are still open
you can see the dark dark holes you know
where where it means that there's
nothing behind them that they are not
clogged so they are they are open sound
can still go
through them and you know usually if
they're
still like in this one probably there's
like
20 percent of goals are still still open
i believe the customer tried to clean
them
by themselves and they did their best so
if you zoom in
you can see the actual the every single
hole
on that net is clogged you can see
something there you know
on the last pair of ones i was using mr
muscle
window and glass street streak free
shine
every single one is clogged so i believe
that like this is completely silent so
it wasn't usable that's for sure
so when the airport is clean and
the the mesh of the speaker it looks
like
nice nice dark gray color and you can
actually see
well through the holes you can see some
you know the dark black you know the
inside of the
of the airport the volume is back it's
loud and clear and
they're usable again i don't want to
look like i'm the pro of the pros of the
airport's cleaning i just
i would like to find a solution that you
know maybe even the diy
solution work you know and keep them
clean and tidy and loud